[Music]
top-4 I cannot believe it I am actually
here and I'm really excited for tonight
and you kind of got the name of the
lip-sync assassin
[Music]
[Applause]
what does that feel like I did um not
something I would have dubbed myself but
you know what I am a performer at heart
and that is what I do
so if that's what I'm dumb and that's my
name hey I'm proud of that last episode
had some mixed feelings about sending
people home yeah I don't want to stand
here and wipe off somebody else's name
and knowing that I was the cause of them
going home so Cameron Lee fan I mean
they're my sisters I of course would not
pick myself I would not want to be in
that position of sending people home but
at the end of the day it is a
competition am I happy I'm still here of
course would I want them here with me
yes but it's a top four and it can only
be for people so unfortunately I was the
one to send them home and it's a
competition at the another day and I'm
glad that I'm here alright well let's
talk about what you're here wearing
tonight what's the inspiration for this
outfit walk me through it um so my
inspiration always comes from fantasy
movies and video games so this is like
my floral elven Queen if you've ever
seen Fern Gully
the the mother fairy I think this kind
of resembles her a little bit and this
is a gown that was made by Diego Montoya
in New York City I love him to make
photos Tasha stuff was something trying
to get away from her aesthetic and into
my own and I think we did it with this
one I think you did this feels very much
like the Camryn we've gotten to know on
the show yes I needed to serve a little
fantasy because I think it died a little
bit towards the end of the show and I'm
glad I got to bring it back tonight
it's back
[Music]
[Applause]